all right today's question comes from
doug in missouri
i'm struggling with how much to help my
son and daughter-in-law financially
they are both mid-30s and she recently
became a veterinarian with about
four hundred thousand dollars in student
loans
which has severely affected their
ability to buy a house or save any money
financially i could easily help them as
i have several millions saved but i want
them to figure this out themselves
however i feel guilty for not helping
them both my wife and i
are afraid it's going to be the wrong
decision i need some perspective
as i'm just not sure what the best thing
to do is
dave do you know how much vets make i
don't
more than a lot of doctors do they i
mean a good
i don't know how long she's been in
practice or where she is but 100 to 200.
okay so if mike
yeah man if you take out 400 000 to
become a doctor whether a doctor of a
person or a doctor of
a animal i think you got to work
together and figure it out
you got to get a long-term plan i've
never been in a position like this
parents in you've got more perspective
on that than i do
i want folks who who signed on a dotted
line
that said um i
agree to that you're going to help me
get my education and i promise to pay
you back
i felt an obligation to pay people back
even when i didn't fully understand what
i was signing at the end of the day i
had to look at that paper and say
i signed it i borrowed it i got to
figure it out so that's where my bent is
um but i've never been in the position
where i could help somebody to a tune of
i could wipe this out one afternoon and
take care of it for them so i get that
temptation for my kids
um yeah but i'm hesitant to do that
what do you think i think most people go
too far one direction or the other okay
lucky just writes the check and they
don't feel any pain and they just
be bop off into the sunset right or
he does nothing and they languish for
years
when he could have stroked the check and
bailed him out
so um the only thing i've been able to
figure out that's kind of in the middle
is if you're going to get my money
you're going to get my coaching
it comes with strings there you go and
my coaching is nothing to do with me
it's not about controlling
it's about you're going to be on a path
that i agree with or i'm not financing
it
right and so if you could get them on a
str
on a tight budget they're not out
spending money like they're crazy
they're
like they're in congress or something
they're they're you know they're on a
budget they're working hard they're
making progress
and you agreed to match
everything they throw to the student
loan
uh as long as they're on a path now if
they're paying 10
on the student loan and they make 350
000 no they're not on a path
but if they're putting 150 000 on that
student loan or 200 000 on it
and they're going to do that in 18
months or something and they're going to
live on beans and rice and they're going
to do the stuff
then you know they got their engine
running i'll pour some gas in their
engine i like that okay so no new cars
no big house yeah they're working a plan
that i think they should work
right which is what they would have to
do if i wasn't there is dad
right and this guy putting the dad shoes
on with this guy right
but if i wasn't there what would they
have to do well they'd be dirt under
their fingernails man i mean they'd be
scratching and clawing right
and so uh but if there's a difference
between abandonment
on one end of the spectrum enabling
right on the other in the spectrum which
is just like oh it's just not fair look
at the student loans we're just going to
write them a check and just forgive all
their student loans and all this crap's
happening in washington right
and it's sad that the girl's got student
loans and i don't want her to i feel bad
for it if you've got student loans out
there i feel bad for you
but i don't want the government to
forgive them right i want you to work
through them and i want us in the
society to come around you and i want
them to stop making the student loans
before they start talking about
forgiving them by the way that's a side
issue too
but um anyway i said that
on our borrowed uh future podcast and
didn't stir up near as much as when i
said it on fox this morning but the uh
uh but anyway the the point being that
yes i want to help them but i want to
help them if they're
getting really invested in helping
themselves if someone is not
doing good things for themselves and you
finance that that is not helping them
correct
that is harming enabling them that's
giving a drunk a drink that's buying a
cocaine addict his next bag
right you know it's like oh you're a
weed addict here i'll buy a bag you know
i mean
that's not helpful to finance
misbehavior finance behaviors that
aren't causing them to win
but if they're moving in the right
direction and i can come alongside them
and say hey
what if you did this this and this and
if you did those three things and you
really play through
i'll do this to add put some gas in your
little engine right but let's get the
little engine going down the little
engine that could right
going down the tracks here and then i
will join hands with them
but you know another example that is i
had a friend that's very wealthy and he
refused to pay for a dime of his kids
college because he had to work his way
through
and so he appreciated his education
because he had dirt under his
fingernails and he had a scratching claw
to get his education and he was he's
worth it
probably a billion dollars wouldn't pay
for a dime of his kids college
and um i i respect that i understand his
reasoning
and i mean he's hardcore right right uh
i paid for 100 of my kids college
yeah but i did not pay for 100 of kids
college who were misbehaving right they
weren't
they're they were walking with god they
weren't down there sleeping around all
over the campus
they weren't doing drugs you know they
weren't drunk in their bed and missing
classes
you know so they were functional
students
right bringing home grades walking a
lifestyle and a life that i approved of
i'll finance that
right well they need to get a job that
is their job then
is behaving you know and and in that
world that's a big job
and i want to talk to folks that are my
age that are
younger than me that are thinking about
college
if you take money from somebody else
they get to speak into how you spend it
that's how that works
and going back to our controlling no
that is a part of the
of the that's a part of the agreement if
i give you money
to go to college if i give you money to
pay off your student loans
i get to speak into how you spend it
because it's mine it's a gift yeah right
and it's this it goes back to that you
had a guy calling me from michigan one
time he said
my son has decided he's going to an
expensive school that we can't afford so
it's going to mean student loan debt
what do i do
my son told me this is what he's doing
and i said well it starts way back when
your son started telling you
this is a six-year-old problem this is a
18 year old problem my son doesn't tell
me stuff i tell him stuff
that's how that works especially when
it's me writing the freaking checks
so i'm going to tell you where my where
your little butt's going to school
if i'm paying for it that's right and so
we don't need to visit colleges i'll
help you with this
that's right that's right you know
because i mean you can visit two
there's two here that are in your budget
[Laughter]
you can go look at them i don't even
need to go with you
and so you don't fall in love with the
beauty of the college campus and go 250
000
in debt to get a degree in left-handed
puppetry but it goes it goes back to
that conversation we're talking about a
segment ago
i want everyone to understand when you
take money from somebody
you're also taking whatever else they're
going to hand you
right whatever else they're going to
demand of you whatever else they're
going to make you do
well and you know when we start talking
about you know we'll parlay this this
guy the answer the question for me is
if they will do smart things help them
help them do smart things
but if they don't want to tell them man
yeah i don't care if you're a
veterinarian i don't care if you're a
surgeon okay if you're a medical doctor
if you have 400 000
in debt you're going to live like a
freshman in college yep until you get
this stuff paid off
i don't care what the people in your
heart tell me about buying a recliner
sit on the bean bag
yup i don't care what your partners are
driving at your at your
veterinary clinic you drive your old car
to get this stuff paid off man
yep exactly and if you're waiting around
the government to fix it let me tell you
what happens
okay they announced you can probably
tell me
it's probably a little well it's 15
years ago roughly the federal government
announced that
the private student loan forgiveness
program oh man
if you work 10 years in an underserved
situation
and you pay your bill on time we'll
forgive the remaining of your debt that
is still there at the end of 10 years
dave i worked with these law students
175 439 people have applied for that
175 000 people applied for that
to date three thousand of the hundred
and seventy five thousand three thousand
one hundred seventy four have gotten it
i worked with so many you're waiting on
the government to fix your life
including the discussions that are going
on up there right now
your life's gonna suck because you're
worshiping a dead god
this is the dave ramsey show